[Music]
on prime crime tonight it's something
parents and teenagers face
almost every day she's got to keep this
secret she's got to keep it hidden
from her mom her dad all of her friends
but what one girl did
was unthinkable
was this a tragedy or murder i think
that she was not being honest
she was either hiding something or
outright lying
[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime crime tonight
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases tonight a
high school girl tries to keep a secret
but it ends in death
this is brook skyler richardson this
girl from ohio had the story we've heard
so many times skylar richardson
by all accounts was a good student she
was well liked at carlisle high school
she was a cheerleader yet like so many
times
things were not quite what they seemed
she had some issues
she had been sexually abused by a boy
that she was interested in when she was
in junior high
and she had been diagnosed by a
psychologist with
dependent personality disorder meaning
she craves
approval and attention from authority
figures
she may seem fine on the outside but on
the inside she's often crumbling because
of her emotional state
skylar also developed an eating disorder
at a very young age
which may have been complicated by her
relationship with her mother kim
it almost seemed like kim richardson was
living vicariously
through her daughter kim richardson was
telling her daughter she know she was
kind of jealous
of her being at the gym and being able
to work out and she was also cheering
her on to
lose weight despite having an eating
disorder in april 2017
at the age of 18 skyler visits her ob
gyn
and he tells her she's about eight
months
pregnant the baby's father trey johnson
a boy she had previously dated
skyler's reaction to the news she said
that
she could not have she was not prepared
to deliver a baby she could not have a
baby
it's never been clear if skylar in fact
knew about her pregnancy prior to that
visit
but what she decided to do after would
prove to be the biggest mistake of her
life
she didn't tell anyone about the baby
including neither trey
nor her parents her mother believed if
she ever had a child
at this point in her life that it would
ruin her life she wouldn't be able to go
to college
she wouldn't get a job she would have to
leave all of that behind and
be a full-time mother skylar would go on
living her life
and in fact she even attended prom she's
fully aware that she's pregnant
she knows that this life is growing
within her but yet she's got to keep
this secret
she's got to keep it hidden from her mom
her dad all of her friends
fast forward to july skylar returns to
her ob gyn's office
but to their shock skylar asks for birth
control pills
and she doesn't have a newborn baby with
her what richardson ends up telling her
doctor
would result in the police now getting
involved
i have a baby and i do anyway okay
honestly when you say
you had the baby boy were you i was in
my bathroom it just came out
um when i pushed and it was breathing
um didn't make any noises skyler claims
that she began experiencing severe
cramps the night of her prom
a possible sign of going into labor two
nights later at her home
she says she gave birth to her baby all
by herself
without waking up her parents or brother
according to skylar though this newborn
whom she named
annabelle didn't survive i put her in my
armpit
she just had a heartbeat just stop
breathing
um how did you how did you i know the
breathing part you can kind of tell and
see did you ever
did you ever hear a cry or a whimper
um did you um when you say she didn't
have a heartbeat did you try to check it
tried to feel i tried i hope i tried to
feel in her chest
um and did you were her eyes open or
closed
they were closed but richardson still
needed to keep this a secret
what she did next changed everything
what do you do when you when you realize
that um that she's not
that she's not going to make it i have
to bury her this was not well thought
out this was
a kind of a hurried frenzied event where
the remains were disposed of
in a very shallow location to mention a
deceased person that she's
just given birth to so that makes this
all the more ominous
investigators are left with a question
did skyler richardson
deliver a stillborn there is that image
of her at prom
and she is pregnant there and i swear
every time i look at that image it
haunts me because
i'm thinking there is a baby there that
you cannot fully appreciate
no one could fully appreciate because
she was masking it so well
could she have bound herself so tightly
that it compromised the baby's ability
to grow
appropriately or did she actually plan
this out
and kill her baby i think that she was
not being honest
she was either hiding something or
outright lying
i always felt that there wasn't
something right that she was bringing
forth
and i thought that that was extremely
obvious whereas other experts
thought the opposite okay um that's okay
i know this
is never meant to hurt
i understand that skyler again like i've
told you we don't think you meant to
hurt her we don't think you hurt her
am i going to be in trouble so what i
don't know
that you're in any trouble what's
especially puzzling is what skyler did
after the night of the birth schuyler's
behavior
after the birth of this child seems to
be anything but normal
she starts going to the gym and working
out
running on the treadmill taking pictures
of her stomach and
sending text messages to her mom showing
her how
she was losing weight and even talking
about how she was going to get rid of
that belly
then there were the internet searches i
think the only thing i search is
how to not have a baby or how to get rid
of a baby but
i never did anything okay well
but let's see how to get rid of a baby
is kind of
really bad now nothing was going to i
didn't try anything
everything suggested that she did not
intend to ever have that baby and it was
affirmative things that she did
to hide her pregnancy i mean remember
she went to the prom just right before
she won up giving birth in her home she
never asked for any help of course from
her family while she was giving birth
she did it all silently while they were
right there
and she had done many internet searches
there was so much there that showed
that that if that baby was born alive it
wasn't going to be alive for very long
the problem for authorities was
annabelle's autopsy
because the body was found in a
decomposed state
the coroner did observe fractures to the
baby's skull
but it was inconclusive if they occurred
before or
after death when we just think about the
fragility if you will
of of a newborn and how susceptible they
are
to any kind of environmental changes
particularly after death
it makes it very hard to read from a
forensic standpoint
at the end of the day we don't have any
soft tissue
that's left behind in order to make an
assessment
as to what kind of trauma the child may
or may not have sustained
at one point during her interview
skyler's parents enter the room
and we get a further look into the
richardson family
i think they want to know if i killed it
myself
yeah you'll go to jail tyler's
relationship with her father
she was a daddy's little girl um he he
loved her very much
mother loved her very much as well kim
richardson
um though had a different type of
relationship with her daughter
it's in the papers it's everywhere it's
the neighbors have already called me
chris jordy called me and i know she was
telling me that they're digging up stuff
in her banker
you're going to be on the news how do
you think men's and pax and bill and
gina also please
support me but i'm just saying
it was pretty shocking her mother was
very concerned
about what the neighbors were going to
think since the police were
digging up their backyard uh what people
were going to say
um she's she it was just a very
different reaction than
the father he seemed a lot more
concerned about his daughter just in
general
you're not going home with us
scott i'm telling you it makes me sick
the cute little bag of popcorn you had
[Music]
you could have forgotten skyler i would
have helped you so many times i told you
if you just tell me i'm always going to
be here for you
i've always told you that i love you how
do you think i
feel the thought of losing my baby what
schuyler didn't know was that an
examination of annabelle's remains was
about to reveal a new clue
and she was going to be brought back in
for more questioning
[Music]
i thought it was my fault because i
shouldn't go the doctor's back and i
just told somebody
so scared i understand
brook scholar richardson was a teenager
out of ohio who told police that she got
pregnant hid this from her family and
friends and then gave
birth alone in her home now she first
tells police
that the baby was born dead but then
something happened
after skyler's interview with detectives
in july 2017
she's free to go but then six days later
they interrogate her again this time
they say they have new evidence
tell me about the fire
there's some evidence to show that there
were
initially it appears that the state's
forensic anthropologist dr beth murray
determined that annabelle's bones showed
signs of burning
while skyler first denies this she then
seems to give in
[Applause]
[Music]
skyler's story of delivering a stillborn
then falls apart
as she reveals new details she didn't
share in her first interview
i know that somehow you know she was
alive like before that
and that's why you're worried you didn't
do something that could have helped why
did she learn
what kind of noise a girl but i
didn't know if it was something else i
saw her arms maybe a little
moving on i i didn't think she was
reading him
too hard okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what she is referring to here is
something in forensics that we refer to
as a compression asphyxia direct
pressure is being applied
where she might clutch this child very
very tight
uh to her chest and the child's chest
can't even begin
to rise and fall how long would be your
closest guess how long she was alive
i don't know what's going to happen if
that is not up to us okay i don't know
do you feel it you keep saying that do
you feel like you should do your
business
when skyler's parents come into the
interrogation room this time
the stakes are much different
[Music]
richardson was charged with a series of
offenses from aggravated murder
to child endangerment her trial began on
september 3rd 2019
while the prosecution seemingly had
strong evidence of
planning motive lying to police and even
the defendant's own words caught on tape
the cracks in their case began to show
there can't be a finding of child
endangerment or murder for that matter
if we don't know that the child was in
fact
dead if the child was born stillborn
there can't be murder
in the aggregate there were a lot of
errors that i think took down the
quality of the case
first that evidence of burning wasn't so
concrete as the investigators who
interrogated skylar initially thought
in email exchanges between dr murray and
the corner
we've learned she believed the bones may
have been charred
and that she felt the prosecution was
upset she wasn't more definitive
with infant skeletal remains these
remains are
very very spongy when the decomposition
process begins
you'll get these kind of blackened or
burned
manifestations on the surface of the
bone that might give it the appearance
of having been burned
they might very well have gone with that
they might very well have said
well yeah the the remains in fact had
been burned when there's not enough
evidence to kind of shore that up
it was an error for the prosecution to
proceed uh
full tilt ahead when they didn't have
that at least hammered out
the coroner ultimately determined that
annabelle died as a result of
homicidal violence but what she couldn't
say
was how it happened she's actually
saying
it's a case of homicidal violence but i
can't tell you any more than that
it's speculative on her part at best
because you cannot say that the child
was choked to death you can't say the
child was strangled
you can't say that the child was
suffocated because there's
there are no indicators there then there
were the interviews
sure schuyler said the things she said
but her defense team argued
police manipulated her into a false
confession
adding to that scott richardson
testified he was never
told that the family's conversations in
that room were being recorded
he was advised skyler didn't need a
lawyer and he believed the police
lied to them all issues that have left
observers
divided i thought that they conducted a
fair interview
and she said so much that could let a
jury determine that she wasn't being
credible
i didn't see that there was any level of
intense pressure or unlawful
unconstitutional pressure
that the police were using during her
interviews skyler's first interview with
police
she's understandably very scared um i
thought
the one detective lieutenant john fein i
thought he was really nice
to her he was trying to provide some
measure of comfort to a young girl who's
gone through something terrible
the second police interview i think in
some ways was pretty disturbing
the female detective kept reaching over
and trying to hold her hand and
you know trying to lead her down this
path to get her to admit that the baby
was
anna would alive to have you as a mom
for being honest about what happened
constant prodding the 17 times of
telling her no we know you burned the
body and
i thought the prodding you know was a
little much at times
but they had that information at the
time and ultimately that information
turned out to be incorrect this concept
of coercion
and an innocent naive girl was
compounded by testimony regarding
skyler's dependent personality disorder
and health issues i think it had more
impact than it should have had and it's
not supposed to be meant
to have a jury or a judge feel sorry
for the defendant with regard to count
one we the jury in the above caption
case find the defendant brook skyler
richardson
not guilty of the offense of aggravated
murder
in the end after four hours of
deliberations
the jury acquitted richardson of the
most serious charges
but they did convict her of gross abuse
of a corpse
i was not surprised by the verdict at
all it was going to be very difficult to
get an
aggravated murder conviction when the
medical experts all testified
that they could not determine the cause
of death because the body was too
decomposed
did miss richardson have overbearing
parents yes did she suffer from an
eating disorder
absolutely but that doesn't mean that
you're allowed to
kill your baby or bury your baby in your
backyard the jury
believed that she improperly disposed of
and desecrated the remains of her child
that is a big deal thank you your honor
i
would do anything and above that you ask
and i understand
and i just wanted to say how sorry i was
i
can sometimes be selfish but i would
like to think that i've
become better in the knowledge that i've
upset everyone
and hurt so many people with what i've
done
and i'm forever sorry and i'm i'm so
sorry
i i'm really really sorry and i
understand
and thank you judge donald oda had an
important decision regarding
richardson's sentence
with the abuse felony carrying up to a
year behind bars
i've always sort of thought of this case
ms richardson
as a story of two little girls
skylar richardson and annabelle
richardson
judge oda didn't sentence skylar
richardson to prison
but rather three years probation
we saw the judge openly empathizing with
her
saying that she reminded him of his
daughter it's bizarre to see the
inequity of justice especially when
you're having
this sort of young sympathetic white
woman
when we see a lot of other justice
delivered to people of color it just
doesn't seem
equitable richardson appeared again in
judge oda's courtroom the following year
for her probation hearing i suffer a lot
in silence and i
i do show remorse and i am very sorry
and i
i heard a lot but i um have been
not showing it as much nothing really
seemed to have changed over the last
year or so
she was supposed to be getting treatment
for her eating disorder but she's still
painfully thin she very much seems
childlike when you listen to her speak
and it surprised me that she hadn't yet
reached out to
tracy johnson the maternal grandmother
of annabelle
to offer any type of apologies it
doesn't seem like
she's really matured that much since
this happened oda ended richardson's
probation
two years early this is a low-level
felony
you have no prior criminal history you
are employed
you are going to college and there is no
reason for me to invest
the time and resources of my probation
department
in supervising you skylar richardson
walked out of that courtroom as a free
woman
but she is a convicted felon and she'll
never
be able to escape what happened i think
that we
as parents owe it to our children to
always let them know
no matter what that we love them that we
care about them
and that no matter how bad anything is
they can always come to us
and tell us
[Music]
there are those who believe that skylar
richardson got away with murder and she
should be in prison
then again there are those who don't see
a killer but a troubled young woman
and look we may never really know how
baby annabelle died
but what we can do is make sure we never
forget her
or this case because that's the way to
prevent this
from happening in the future that's all
we have for you on prime crime tonight
leave us your comments on the brook
schuyler richardson case on twitter or
facebook with the hashtag
primecrimetonight
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
[Music]
you